Jocko,
I coach high school football,
which should I do with the star athlete
who's segregates himself and won't
participate in hard drills or it won't
participate hard in drills. Yeah.
Now this one,
I actually thankfully remembered that I
said I would do this because when I got
this,
this is a Twitter question and I responded
to this Twitter question in one word.
So you know, he says, I got this guy, Star
athlete, he won't participate in drills.
What should I do with him? I responded
in one word bench thought that.
So, so of course, you know,
then people start saying, well,
you know, and I was like,
yeah, I know we're on Twitter,
right? We're on Twitter. Uh,
there's more to it then what's happening?
I just answered 798 questions and this
was 799 so I'm not going to go into full
detail. But then as people were kind
of chime in and I was like, okay, I'll,
I'll answer this on the podcast so
we can go into it a little bit more.
Because yes, your coach, your leader,
and obviously I talk
about this all the time,
leadership is a nuanced thing.
It takes balance,
it takes maneuvering, it takes
chess playing, it takes mental,
Jujitsu, it takes all those things, right?
So the obvious answer of just like bench,
that's my meat head answer.
And fundamentally we'll get to it,
but,
and fundamentally that may be the result,
but let's dive into it a little bit.
Who's The kid? What's his deal? What's
his background? What's his attitude?
Where's he coming from?
What's his family like life?
Or what's his family life like?
What is,
what's his past performance? What's
his record? What year is he in school?
I mean there's all kinds of
things we need to know, right?
So now once we've sort of figured out
what he liked now that any one of those
things,
any one of those variables is going to,
is going to change our course
of action a little bit.
Because being the leader doesn't mean
you get to follow a cookie cutter results
or cookie cutter solutions to things,
right?
You're dealing with human beings and
every single human being is different,
and every single human being has a
little craziness to him that you cannot
predict. So we're dealing with a
kid. Guess what? A 16 year old boy,
that kid is even more unpredictable and
even more crazy than most because he's
got testosterone flowing through his
system. He's chasing girls, he's,
he's just going crazy.
He's not secure with himself yet.
He's got zits on his face. He's,
you know, he's got things going on,
he's got issues. And so this kid is crazy
and we're trying to deal with it now.
Most kids can get,
you know,
they get through that and they're
still participating with the team.
This gets not, so one of the
first things I always say this,
you got somebody that's not stepping up
into leadership position or they're not
wandering. You put them in charge
of it. You know, you say, Hey, echo,
I want you to run this drill.
I think the way I'm watching
you perform on the field,
but I think you could really
lead this drill. Well,
I want you to lead this drill and show
these guys what's up, right? Oh, so,
so you know what I mean?
Like he's got a little fired up
face on your look just there.
So that might take his attitude. And
now instead of me saying, Hey Echo,
you've got to do this
drill like everyone else.
I already know that you don't want to do
that. So I'm elevating you a little bit,
given your ego, a little
push, a little massage,
and maybe you feel good about that
now. And I say, Hey, you know,
you can run this drill faster than
anyone else. I want you to lead it.
I want you to show them how to do it. I
want you to make our team better. Boom.
All of a sudden you're getting
a little fired up. So that's,
that's one solution type,
right?
I'm just getting kind of a broad solution
types on. Another solution type is is,
and this is real easy,
real easy,
is when you're talking to someone that
you want to improve their performance,
you don't go to them and say, Hey, uh,
you need to get better because you're
just right now you're letting the whole
team down and you're just,
you think you're all good.
You think you're so good
that you don't need to coach.
You don't need to run drills with the
team. You need to run drills to the team.
Now your attitude is what
are you talking about?
So instead of saying that I again,
I'm going to eagle you up a
little bit and be say, Hey man,
I'm going to talk to you.
I've got to talk to you because I see so
much potential with you with your game.
I see your athletic ability and I see
the way that the other guys on the team
look at you. You might not sense it.
They look up to you. You're a leader,
whether you want to be a leader or not,
and the potential that you have and is
as an athlete is not going to come to
fruition unless you at least get some
of your potential as a leader in line.
So the reason I want you to run these
drills isn't to make you better.
I already know you're good.
I already know you're good at the drills.
The reason I want you to run these
drills, Chi, wants you to be even better.
I want you to reach your potential.
And by the way you help and run these
drills is going to make the team better.
And the better the team does,
the better you're going to do.
The more scouts we're going
to here looking at you.
So there's that,
and obviously I'm gonna explain to him
why the drills are important for him and
for the team and for am and the team
together for the all everyone to reach
their potential. So those
were, those are good too.
I guess overall,
broadly what I'd be doing this
whole time is talking to the person,
talking to the individual,
trying to figure out
what his reasons were for not wanting
to participate in the drills and then
countering those reasons with
logical answers and you know,
saying,
Hey,
here's why it's important and explaining
it to them and then eventually you're
going to get to a point where my
coaching, my explaining, my maneuvering,
my mental Jujitsu,
none of it's worked and he's still
telling me I'm not running the drills.
I don't need to. Cool.
Bench next question.
You know what I mean? Well, you
played ball. What do you think? Yeah,
because I didn't play football. Yeah,
no, that's exactly right. I would,
I would think,
and I'm trying to put myself
in the mindset back when
I was in high school. Oh,
I remember
going into my senior year. So you have
a, we had some kind of summer training,
so it was really like high school summer
training. Edis no, no, no. That was,
that was for fall. Okay. Um, and
that was like a camp situation,
but no summer training,
which was like after spring and
stuff in it and what they'd call it,
they call it technique sessions.
And all it was was like, you know,
I played in high school was
kind of like a slap back,
which is a hybrid running back
wide receiver type. And um,
so the technique sessions were just
kind of passing drills and you know,
just hand stuff and maybe even some
foot work. But it was kind of fun.
It was just,
you know,
the quarterback who was there and the
receivers in the writing back then you
catch passes, run routes and stuff and you
know, for like, I don't know, 45 minutes,
hour.